Now, note, even from the cross, he
willed himself to die.
He willed himself to die.
You notice.
And we'll look at various versions.
Well, this doesn't actually translate
perfectly.
Focus, everyone.
Everyone focus, do not be distracted, so
I don't be distracted.
John 19:28-34.
But after this, Jesus knowing that all
things had already been finished.
Tetelestai. Tetelestai.
In order to finish the scripture, he
said, "I am thirsty." Um when I unpack
this part, please ask the spirit to
remind me and unpack this.
Amos 8:9-10, darkness on the land.
Exodus 10, I got a lot. Boy, we're going
to have a feast tonight. Sit back, don't
go anywhere, get your pizza, popcorn, as
we mourn the death of our Lord and
Savior who will
rise on Sunday.
Our Lord is beautiful. His word is
beautiful.
A jar full of sour wine was standing
there.
So, they put a sponge full of the sour
wine. Notice, it's
bitter, right?
And a branch of hyssop.
Hyssop, right? When you read Exodus 12
about eating the Passover lamb,
right? What's involved is
bitter herbs, hyssop.
I will look at it real quickly. May my
memory not fail me. Brought it up to his
mouth. Therefore, when Jesus had
received the sour wine, he said, "It is
finished." Notice, he willed [snorts]
himself to die. Bowing his head, he gave
up his spirit.
Even from the cross.
He
willed himself to die.
No one took his life from him. He's
proving his words.
You got it over there, camcorder,
everyone else?
That's why they were
shocked.
Because Sabbath was about to spring up
on them.
This is what they would do to hasten the
death
of the crucified.
They would break the legs of the
victims.
Break the legs of the victims.
Right?
So, that they couldn't push up with
their feet and breathe. Again, you're
blessed and spoiled with the amount of
information that's available to you just
by internet.
We now know from archaeological,
textual,
inscriptions, and documentation
that
the victims would have to push with
their legs to breathe.
Because they'd be in a position where
they're in a collapsed position, bones
stretched out, they'd have to push up to
breathe.
Now, imagine doing that all day, you
then drain
and have no more energy to push up
to breathe. So, when you break the legs,
they can't push up anymore, they
suffocate and die.
Right?
So, in order to hasten the death of the
victims,
because Sabbath was about to dawn,
they went and broke the legs of the two
victims, but they saw Jesus was dead.
They're caught by surprise. Why? Cuz
Jesus was showing you, "They can't take
my life from me. None of you can take my
life from me. I choose when to die, and
I die now."
You understand?
He is proving to you in the garden and
on the cross, he's in control of his
death. They don't control his death.
He controls
his death.
They don't.
He determines when he'll be arrested,
who will arrest him,
whether they can beat him and flog him,
and when he will die on the cross, not
them. Right here.
Then the Jews, because of their
preparation,
it's a high Sabbath because it's falling
on Passover week, so that the bodies
would not remain on the cross on the
Sabbath, for that Sabbath is a high sab-
high day,
asked Pilate that their legs might be
broken and that they might be taken
away. So, the soldiers came and broke
the legs of the first man and of the
other who was crucified with him.
But coming to Jesus,
when they saw that he's already dead,
they did not break his legs, and I'm
going to show you why. This fulfills the
Passover lamb, Exodus [clears throat]
12:46.
Right?
But one of the soldiers pierced his side
with a spear, and immediately blood and
water came out. The cat's manifesting
again.
We'll talk about the significance of
these in a moment. If not today,
tomorrow, God willing. We'll see how
much we can cover.
All right, everyone ready now?
So, what do we learn? Now, let me show
you Mark 15.
When when
Joseph of Arimathea went to ask for the
body of Pilate,
Pilate was stunned.
Why was he stunned? Mark 15:40.
Right?
He was stunned to find out he was
already dead.
Now, watch. Mark 15:
37-39.
37, look what happens.
Where does it
And Jesus
uttering a loud cry, breathed his last.
Literally,
gave up his spirit.
Notice 37. And the veil of the sanctuary
is torn in two from top to bottom. So,
the earliest gospel and the latest
gospel agree. Don't let them lie to you
say, "Oh, that's John making things up,
making Jesus look better than he did."
Mark tells you he gave up his spirit,
literally. I'll show you other
translations.
Where this is gave up his spirit,
breathed out his spirit.
Gave up his spirit. This is why some
translations are better than others. It
should have been rendered gave up his
spirit. All right, we'll look at it. And
the veil of the sanctuary is torn in top
from bottom top to bottom.
And when the And I'll talk about this
later. In time,
we'll talk about this. So, when the
centurion was standing right in front of
him saw the way, see, he breathed See,
he was astonished.
A centurion, an expert executioner.
Right?
Ex-
expert
executioner.
An expert
at making sure
criminals died
and knew,
being a professional executioner,
right?
When someone is dead.
He's astonished by our Lord's death.
When he saw that the Lord willed himself
to die, see? Saw when he breathed out
the way he died, he was blown away.
What manner of man is this?
What manner of man is this
that can even will himself to die?
See that?
Hello, you guys.
You guys
Uh and the centurion who was standing
right in front of him saw the way he
breathed his last,
he said, "Truly, this man was God's
son."
Now, watch.
Pilate was shocked. Watch here.
And when evening had already come,
because it was preparation day, that is,
the day before the Sabbath,
you're a perfect note, Mark and John
perfectly agree as to the day.
Joseph of Arimathea came, a prominent
council member who himself was waiting
for the kingdom of God, and he gathered
up courage, went in before Pilate, asked
for the body of Jesus, and Pilate was
amazed. He wondered if he had died
by this time. So, he summoned the
centurion, and he questioned him as to
whether he already died. Wait, wait,
wait. He's already dead?
See [snorts] it?
He's already dead?
These were professional killers,
executioners.
So, they're astonished. He died already?
And ascertaining
this from the centurion, he granted the
body to Joseph.
So, Mark agrees with John. There is no
theological embellishment evolution.
It's the same message from different
perspectives.
The Lord
decided to die that moment. He summoned
his spirit
to leave his body. He summoned
death to come. No one took it away from
him.
Now, let me show you
other translations why
you need translations that capture
right?
The Greek better. And Jesus cried with a
voice and gave up the ghost. Your
beautiful King James Bible.
When the Centurion stood which stood
over against him saw that he so cried
out and gave up the ghost. That's why he
was astonished. He heard him summon his
spirit to leave his body and then when
he died, he was astonished and he knew
this is no mere human. He must be a
divine son of God.
Just like he claimed.
See how much I have to unpack? All of
this is proving this is the God-man.
You see it?
Gave up the ghost. Let's see how the
Douay-Rheims renders it.
See your Bibles? Breathe his last. Why
would you say that? Just say he gave up,
he breathed out his spirit.
Breathing your last won't impress
anyone.
How many people breathe their last and
die? Note the manner in which he died
shocked the Centurion and convinced him.
Right?
Here's your Douay-Rheims, gave up the
ghost.
Your Douay-Rheims, Elizabethan English
Shakespearean English and here it is.
Seeing that crying out in this manner he
had given up the ghost. Now guys
many people breathe their last and no
one gets astonished.
What would lead
What would lead the Centurion, a
professional killer executioner to be in
awe and amazed at the way he died?
Cuz he saw him summon his spirit to
leave his body.
Not he breathed his last.
How many of you have been at deathbeds
and a person breathed his last? There's
nothing extraordinary about that.
Everyone got this so far?